Thanks.
Um,
as Professor [inaudible] said,
I'm going to talk today about the French
Empire from 1871 the year that the
course begins to 1914,
which is the beginning of World War One.
Of course,
uh,
which is something that you'll
talk about if I'm not mistaken,
uh,
in the lecture right after this one.
So I'm going to start the lecture with
a passage from a French novel called
Lumet flooded I math,
uh,
the master of the sea.
It was written by one vehicle,
Michelle,
the Boogie and published in 1900.
So right in the middle of the
period we're talking about,
the novel was about an army officer who
was so upset by the defeat at the hands
of Prussia and the loss of assessing the
hen that he leaves France to go serve
in a regiment in the Sudan
in the heart of west Africa.
At one point during the novel,
the young officer returns to France
and he meets an older general from his
father's generation.
So during their conversation,
the older general expresses some anger
that the officer's seemed to be more
concerned with adventuring in his words.
Then with recovering the land where
his father's generation had fallen,
the young officer replied to him,
this is a quote.
Are we to blame if the world around
us has changed and grown all out of
recognition,
diplomacy?
It used to be concerned with the
Mediterranean and the Bosphorus.
Now it has to do with China and the Congo.
The Great States of Europe are dividing
up the other continents of Africa and
Asia in the way they used to divide
up countries like Italy and Poland.
What used to be a European balance of
power is now a world balance of power and
any country which does not
wish to become less important,
must obtain as much new territory
as our rivals are doing.
It is through colonies.
Can Cute,
concluded the young officer that she,
we shall one day achieve
your life's ambition.
The ambition of the older general.
I give you my word of honor.
He said that you are mistaken in thinking
that they say ambition has died in our
hearts
during the period I'm talking about today.
The French empire quite literally exploded
and Empire that in 19 1871 had been
little more than parts of Algeria and a
military presence presence in parts of
North Africa,
Southeast Asia,
and a few small spits of land in the
Pacific and the Caribbean exploded to
include large swathes of
North Africa and West Africa.
Most of mainland Southeast Asia,
parts of the Middle East and territories
in the Pacific and the Caribbean as
well.
By the end of World War One.
And the French empire span 11 million
kilometers and a hundred million
inhabitants.
So just to put it in
the context of France,
that's twice as many people as lived
in metropolitan France at that time,
roughly.
So I chose the passage from the novel to
begin this lecture because it captures
what I think are the two central themes
in this period and French colonial
history.
Both the young officer in the older gen
in the novel are serving in the French
army because they are obsessed with
recovering the national strength and
prestige that France had lost,
the devastating defeat depression now.
But the older general thinks about
this in terms of recovering on SAS,
they'll hand in terms of
continental rivalries,
but the young officers sees Francis Road
to greatness in very different terms.
He sees it overseas outside of Europe.
So my first point is that in these decades
after 1871 French nationalism became
increasingly inseparable from the idea
of a large and strong colonial empire.
France had had colonies for a long time,
but the fusion of a more modern and mass
form of nationalism with colonialism
was new and French history to this period
and it was something that drove the
explosion of the French Empire that I
just described to its heights in the years
just after World War One.
The second point that I want to make
about the novel is simply that it was a
novel.
It was one of many novels written about
empire during this period and novels
were just one of the many forms of popular
culture that began to reflect Francis
growing presence overseas.
Indeed during the late 19th century
empire became something that more and more
French people experienced directly,
whether through popular
culture or sometimes in much
more active ways serving in
the army or navy or in
colonial administrations,
or even settling lens that had not been
part of France when those people were
born.
So what I would like you to take away
from this lecture is that during the third
republic empire became a central
part of French national identity.
Empire was something that all political
platforms in France discussed and took
positions on.
It was part of the idea of French
national greatness that citizens were
beginning to learn in the
schools of the republic.
It was in the national newspapers that
more and more people were reading and it
even for some became a
career and a way of life.
So in its many forms,
empire during this period became a
common experience for French people,
whether they were from
Brittany or from Burgundy,
from provost,
or the APP Dash.
In short,
empire was a central part
of making people French.
Although it was in the decades after
1871 that Francis colonial empire truly
became a part of national identity.
Empire had a long past and French history
during the 17th and 18th centuries.
France had territories in the Caribbean
and of course in North America,
although many of these were lost during
the era of the French Revolution,
one of the revolutions,
most powerful legacies was the idea
of a moral imperative to continue the
revolution beyond Francis borders.
In other words,
France had not only a right but a duty
to bring French civilization to the rest
of the world,
even if he isn't even as the revolution
raged in France at the close of the 18th
century,
the republic's armies had poured outward
into Europe to bring the rights of man
to the monarchies of the continent.
This continued,
of course with Napoleon who extended the
reach of the nation completely across
Europe before its hands froze
in the cold Russian planes.
Napoleon also believed,
and this is important,
that France was destined
to quote unquote civilized,
those who were not only not French,
but not European.
Napoleon attempted to colonize Egypt at
the turn of just at the turn of the 19th
century and his attempt to combined a
messianic belief in science and progress,
an absence of any real knowledge about
non western world and a predisposition
for the idea that non white
races were inferior to whites,
to Europeans.
And this was a potent combination of
nationalism with ideas about race and
civilization that would drive French
colonialism until its bitter end.
This combination came to be known in
French as the museum CVDs that feast,
the civilizing mission,
the idea that a Greco Roman
heritage Christianity,
the legacy of the enlightenment,
modern science capitalism,
that all these things made France
inherently superior and gave it a moral
responsibility to export these legacies
of its civilization to the less
fortunate.
So although France had a long history
of empire at the birth of the third
republic in 1871 the upheavals of many
revolutions and the Paris commune meant
that the overseas empire had been fairly
small for a long time and that it was
at that point pretty marginal in national
politics and culture in the years
before the French to defeat by Prussia,
the French government's control over
territorial expansion was actually pretty
limited.
The main urge to expand came
not from French politicians,
but often from soldiers and sailors in
far off places who were often prompted by
missionaries who urged intervention to
save souls or by businessmen who urged
intervention to make a quick fall.
Even the bulk of French expansion in
Algeria after 1830 Algeria was really
Francis major colony and the years and
for most of the 19th century even this
was largely the work of generals who
wave the flag and shot their rifles often
in direct opposition to the wishes
of national governments in Paris.
So at times it really seemed like the
French empire was little more than a giant
system of relief for the armed services.
As one a former colonial governor wrote,
what drove us to expand in faraway places
was a ball above all the need to find
something to occupy the army and the navy.
But this began to change in important way
as after 1871 in French politics after
the end of the disastrous
war with pressure.
You're overriding question for many was
how France could regain its place as a
national power,
as a great power among among Europe,
the war with Prussia had shown that
Germany was a nation on the and England's
dominance in world affairs,
especially its empire was,
was unquestioned.
As you all know by now,
politics in France during the 1870s and
the 1880s were tumultuous to say the
least as France hobbled
from one FAF to the next.
So critics attack the republic as
a cesspool of intrigue and scandal.
Aperiodic industrial downturns,
broad political challenges
from left and right as blown.
Chisholm and socialism both
threatened to overthrow the republic.
France also suffered from the lowest
birth way among western European nations.
So emasculated,
militarily,
slumping,
economically shrinking.
Demographically,
France appeared to many people to
be in a state of inevitable decline,
staring at the specter of national
stagnation and fading international
relevance.
Many luminaries of the young
third republic believed
that the key to recovering
Francis greatness lay in the
expansion of its colonial empire.
Perhaps the most famous of these
advocates of colonial expansion among the
political elite was June Fetty,
who was of course the famous advocate
of the Eco Lipid weekend in the battles
over that and the 1870s and eighties
eighties Betty's arguments for imperial
expansion in many ways encapsulate
French colonial ideology in the late 19th
century,
very believed in his,
in his words,
quote,
that colonial policy was the daughter
of industrial policy enrich states were
capitol abounds and accumulates where
the manufacturing system is undergoing
continual growth.
Export is an essential
factor in public prosperity.
In other words,
colonies were essential to
a strong national economy
and the rise of Germany and
even the rise of the United States and
Russia meant that France needed exclusive
access to new markets and sources for
raw materials that in the eyes of many
people,
only colonies could provide the closely
tied to these economic imperatives of
empire.
We're strategic ones,
rivalries between nations in Europe as
they often had in the past spilled out
into the rest of the world and a nation
that wished to survive had to compete.
This is Fetty again in today's Europe.
In this competition of the
many rivals who's power we are,
see,
we see growing around us.
A policy of abstention is very simply
the road to decadence in the times in
which we live nation's are only great
in accordance with the activities which
they develop,
exerting ourselves without action.
Regarding all expansion in Africa and
the Orient as a trap or an adventure to
live in this way,
believe me,
is to abdicate our position and to
tumble from the first to the third or the
fourth rank of nations.
Fetty also believed in what he called
the humanitarian and civilizing side of
the question.
In his words,
superior races have a right
visa vi inferior races he wrote,
but they also have a duty,
and this is echoing the language of,
of the French revolution almost directly.
They also have a duty
to bring civilization,
Western government,
education,
medicine and morals to other peoples.
So for men likes you to Fetty.
It was the greatness of the nation of
the French nation that made the expansion
of the French empire,
not only necessary but legitimate.
It was the colonial empire that would
save France from losing ground to its
rivals and that would help elevate the
cultures and the civilizations of the
peoples that France colonized.
So the 1880s politicians like fairly
brought Francis colonial ambitions into
national politics in
ways never seen before.
And you just a few years after national
political power swung decisively to the
Republicans.
In 1879 if Eddie's government launched
a campaign to try to jumpstart Francis
stagnating presence in Southeast Asia
by taking over the northern half of what
is now Vietnam was done called Tonkin
and the French had tried to take this on
several occasions,
but it failed on the pretext of defending
persecuted Vietnamese Catholics and
attacking pirates.
The French sent several companies of
soldiers north to attack the Capitol of
Hanoi.
The campaign,
was it just a little too ambitious?
The French captain,
a man named lead,
yeah.
Ended up with his head on a pike
staff in the middle of the city.
Yup.
This happens in places other than France.
Head's getting cut off
that he's aggressive.
Colonial expansion was,
was really very unpopular at first.
Josh Glam also accused him of high
treason and crowds outside shouted for
fatties head on a pike.
Staff next to leave.
Yes.
Nevertheless,
ferries,
insertion of colonial affairs onto
the national stage was a sign of the
prominence that empire would come to
play in national politics in the years to
come.
Just after fatties demise
in national politics,
French colonial activity began to expand
at a rapid rate as the third republic
race to compete with the British
and the Germans and the Dutch.
By the 1890s debates over colonial
policy had become a standard part of
discussions and the Chamber of deputies
and every government after Jude failures
presided over a steadily
expanding colonial empire.
This new prominence of colonial issues
in French national politics was in many
ways due to the activities of a growing
and very influential colonial lobby in
French society.
In many ways,
it was this colonial lobby that was most
responsible for imagining and spreading
the idea that national greatness was
closely tied to colonial expansion.
So what was this colonial lobby?
I want to emphasize that it was not a
single organization or formal movement.
It really was more a large and
very diverse group of end of,
uh,
of individuals and associations who put
forward the case for colonial expansion
and in many different ways,
the colonial lobby was not organized
by an executive committee and had no
organized sections or no clearly
defined program or electoral platform.
It was far beyond the vocal colonial
activists or advocates in the Chamber of
Deputies.
It included men like the informal group
of explorers and geographers who met
every week in Paris at the [inaudible]
to share their fascination with exotic
places and to talk about
how the government might be
able to better promote and
support these voyages of exploration.
The colonial lobby included shipbuilders
and railway magnates and factory
owners,
people who believe that the colonies were,
were the way to where the path
to to untold material wealth.
It included missionaries who saw in the
quote unquote heathen races of Africa
and Asia,
a potential source for converts to replace
the French who were starting to skip
church and starting to use birth
control and greater numbers and included
writers and journalists for whom
the culinary is the colonies were,
were,
were a little more than good copy.
So those are made up the colonial
lobby warrant United at all by the same
interests.
But it was precisely this diversity of
their interests that shows how compelling
empire is becoming for so many
different parts of French society.
So indeed during the 1880s and 1890s
the assumption increasingly became that
through the French
colonies served the nation.
They serve the nation as a whole in ways
that went further and further beyond
economic and geostrategic necessities.
Many parts of French society increasingly
came to see empire as a solution to
national problems.
In the words of the historian Glen,
Gwendolyn Wright,
the colonies were quote unquote,
a laboratory of modernity.
There were places to further and
protect the destiny of the nation,
literally quite literally through
experiments in nation building before the
third republic,
colonies had been seen really as the
social value of colonies was little more
than than seen as,
as getting rid of people that the
state considered to be undesirable.
Um,
the French penal colony in New Caledonia,
it was a good example of this.
We're over 4,000 of the community had
been sent in 1871 but toward the end of
the century,
this began to change.
Social reformers began to see the
colonies as a potential home for landless
peasants,
for the unemployed,
or even for orphans who
had no home in France.
In other words,
colonies were places that could serve
to solve the nation's problems and not
merely locked them up
and throw away the key.
French engineers and social planners
came to see the empire as a really a vast
worksite where new forms of
architecture and urban planning,
uh,
could,
could be carried out places where
experiments could be carried out to help
benefit France.
You definitely Otay was a famous
French military officer and future
administrator in the colony of Morocco.
He insisted that North Africa,
West for France quote,
what the Far West is for America,
an excellent testing ground for
creating new energy rejuvenation.
And for [inaudible],
the French military likewise saw colonies
as a training ground where the army
and the navy could protect and
expand Frances overseas interests.
And in doing so could learn to
better defend the nation at home.
So as empire became a more important
part of French national debates,
it also started to become an increasingly
central part of popular culture and
life in France,
schoolchildren began reading
about colonies in textbooks.
One directive from the
Ministry of Education.
Read that quote.
It must not be forgotten that France is
a world power which possesses colonies
in all parts of the earth.
Let us not have any scruples
about retaining for two years,
just two years.
The attention of French youth on France.
Let us give them as rich an image as
possible for their country of the mother
country and her distant daughters.
French citizens already out of school
began to learn about the empire in
different ways.
For example,
the urban middle classes who visited the
Museum of man or the Museum of natural
history in Paris began to
see collections of art,
of clothing and household objects and
other things collected in the French
empire by scientific societies that
were brought back to Paris to be put on
display.
The colonies were put on display
and even more spectacular fashion at
international expositions,
which were held in Paris in 1878 1889
and 1900 the exposition of 1900 which
quite literally took over the city of
Paris and that exposition colonies were
for the first time given their own
separate exhibition grounds in the gardens
behind the Takata Hook Palace.
Across the sin from the
Eiffel Tower and we're quote,
set apart enough by the river to permit
the creation of an atmosphere different
from the rest of the fair.
Entire colonial buildings were transported
to Paris and rebuilt colonial work.
Men were brought to France to execute
the detail and decorative work in the
buildings and they remained
there throughout the exhibition,
posing as residents and merchants in
the reconstructed villages and bizarres
from far away mosques,
temples,
archeological discoveries,
dancers,
music,
and food.
All were brought to create
a self contained world
that attempted to represent
Frances growing empire to
the average French person.
The empire was more than a periodic
occasion for spectical colony.
Slowly but surely crept into the
most mundane forms of everyday life.
Readers of French newspapers,
for example,
like the put usual,
not read more and more about
the French empire every day.
As it grew.
For the most part,
articles focused on military encounters
and on the French who fought in them.
African or Asian opponents merely filled
the need in these stories for an evil
or a savage enemy.
There were backdrop for main characters
in a drama that unfolded every day.
A story that more and more
Frenchmen love to follow.
Other readers read novels that
evoked the exotically different,
the strange customs of natives,
the bright colors and the pungent odor
is overseas and the lure of the desert,
or if the jungle Pierre,
hello t,
who was one of the most
famous of these writers,
wrote panoramas of colonial life
that were packed with adventure,
with danger,
with sex,
and with local color,
quote unquote,
in which hardy Frenchmen
lived the rough life,
the sensual pleasures,
and the fighting spirit of the empire.
Artists like Paul Gauguin and all
he Matisse began painting Levantine,
Harems and souks African
villages and jungles,
temples in Indochina and native life.
Throughout the empire,
colonies were a rich source of subjects
for the growing medium of photography.
Photographers liked photographing the
rice patties and the Mekong River Buddhist
monks and saffron robes,
mysterious Muslim women behind
veils and cannibals with spears.
These images were reproduced
in books and newspapers,
postcards,
and other places.
The French encountered an empire in
many other ways in their daily lives.
Colonial influences began
to be heard in music.
For example,
cafe and dance hall goers
heard songs like my Beltone.
[inaudible] was about a
Frenchman's Vietnamese concubine.
I can't resist.
I'm going to read it.
Not Too
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
don't you here at your window.
He who loves you,
your quartermaster and back
from Tonkin where I finished.
Happy to see you.
My darling.
I've left my beautiful Dunkin was for you.
My charming,
false wise.
You are the most beautiful of the aisle,
far from you.
I was not at peace.
More bourgeois music lovers
hoard orchestral works by
composers like cause I've
had in Debussy who were fascinated
by the sounds of the Orient.
The colonies also came
to suggest new fashions,
oriental silks and 17 frocks popular
in women's clothing in the early 20th
century owed much to this
fascination with the exotic,
even the goods that people
bought increasingly evoked
the colonies often through
advertising.
One of the most famous
French advertisements ever,
for example,
is the publicity for Ben and Ya.
A sweet powdered beverage made from
bananas that when mixed with milk makes a
breakfast food.
The yellow banana bucks featured a
derogatory caricature of a smiling African
uttering the pigeon
Frisch craze in French.
You have wound by Nina.
Good stuff,
but then yeah,
things like this brought the empire all
the way to the breakfast tables of many
French families.
French people even began to
encounter the empire in church.
The last third of the 19th century was
a time of intense Catholic missionary
activity outside of France,
usually in the French colonies
and church goers in France.
Listen to the appeals of their priests,
the donate money to help
a French missionary from
their defacto mall away and
far off.
Indochina or Senegal replace a little
bamboo or Straw chapel with a proper brick
church.
Of course,
there was no better way to
experience or more intense way,
I would say,
to experience empire than
to actually go there.
And then late 19th century,
more and more French people that exactly
that until the 1880s and the 1890s
there were relatively few French
people in territories that the French
controlled is colonies with
the exception again of Algeria,
which had about 300,000 French settlers
in 1871 this really wasn't exception.
Um,
even by the 1880s or 1890s,
places like Indochina only had probably
between 20 and 30,000 at the most,
maybe even less.
So at first,
many of these French colonies had little
more than administrators' garrisons of
troops and some explorers and missionaries
beating the bush for riches or for
souls.
Gradually,
however,
more and more French citizens
came to overseas territories,
not for adventure,
but just to make a living.
The part of French society most
immediately affected of course,
was the military which
went to the colonies in
increasingly greater numbers as
the empire and resistance to it spread
soldiers and the empire risked long sea
journeys and tropical diseases
and miserable pay for the
risk and the adventure
that they thought that
they might find over there.
Missionaries to,
as I mentioned,
when overseas more and more
toward the end of the century,
to try to find converts that they weren't
finding in France apart from soldiers
and traders and missionaries were
settlers who increasingly went to the
colonies,
not for a tour of duty,
but they went there to stay.
Settlers were often committed to the
colonies for life that gave up the
resources they possessed at home.
They took to the colonies,
whatever capital and whatever possessions
they could get and they could carry
with them.
The colonies were not hospitable places,
and needless to say,
remoteness from France and relatives,
tropical diseases in a very understandable
hostility of indigenous populations.
We're a major deterrent for many people.
However,
a number of French men and women
did dare a new life in the Maghreb,
in Indochina or in West Africa.
Many were drawn by the inducements of
people who owned large tracts of land and
who needed people to work in,
cultivate this land to
help them turn a profit.
When there weren't enough Frenchmen,
landowners didn't hesitate to populate
their lands with non-French Europeans
like Italian and Spanish,
some of whom were also in the colonies.
As members of the famous
international military force,
the lesion with Tom Shia foreign legion.
As the French empire grew,
life in the empire became
more slowly more regularized.
The French government began to replace
soldiers and sailors with administrators
who exercise the will of the state.
These administrators' held
responsibility for collecting taxes,
for overseeing spending,
and for keeping law and order,
which often meant authorizing violence
against those who resisted the spread of
the French empire.
Increasingly,
these administrators came not
from the ranks of the military,
but from new schools founded in France
to train people for service and the
empire.
One of the most famous of these was the
[inaudible] founded in 1887 which taught
future administrators a little bit about
the language and the culture of the
place that they were being sent,
as well as the basics of the position
that they were going to fill when they
were over there.
The French government also did its best
to draw professionals to newly acquired
territory's lawyers,
doctors,
engineers,
surveyors.
All of these were much needed in,
in,
in the empire and Paris offered subsidies
to get qualified candidates to take a
post overseas.
As the empire continued to grow,
more and more women came to live in these
places that had for a long time been
perceived as much too dangerous for them.
In many ways,
the domesticity that the arrival of women
brought to French life in the colonies
was the clearest sign of the,
the idea of domesticating and even taming
French colonies and integrating them
into the sphere of greater France.
Places that had once been considered too
dangerous for women became places where
women eager to Mary
went to find a husband,
a book called [inaudible].
The woman in the colonies published in
1900 assured interested women that the
empire could provide a
hospitable home quote.
A woman who arrives in don't count,
for example,
is sure of success.
There are no women in,
in,
in Tonkin who failed to marry.
There were of course women who did not
go to the colonies simply for marriage.
And even those who did found themselves
pushed out of normal social expectations
by the necessities of colonial life.
Many women in the colonies,
for example,
we're drawn into humanitarian work
at hospitals or in dispensaries are
orphanages,
which is ironic in light of the positions
that many of their husbands held in
the colonial administration doing work
that couldn't exactly be described as
humanitarian of course.
So just to put the expansion of the
French population in the colonies and the
context of one place,
let me just mention the Algerian town
of antibiotic during this period before
the French conquest and about
had a population of about
4,000 Arabs and Berbers,
some Turks and a fairly
large Jewish population.
The French captured on about fairly
early in 1832 but for many years,
the European population of the city was
really little more than the soldiers who
kept control of the city.
By the mid 1840s however,
there were 5,000 Europeans at
times went by as time went by,
mines and forests in that area became
an attractive source of employment for
people.
A railway line was built and the city
and for infrastructure slowly grew.
In fact,
the city was also at that
time renamed Boone I,
transient population of,
of Europeans,
mostly French evolved into
a rooted and stable one.
By the 1890s Europeans born in Boone,
outnumbered migrants from overseas and
French citizens formed the majority of
the residents of the city.
Algeria was by far,
of course the French colony with
the largest friends population.
But the others grew and grew during this
time and by World War One and it would
be almost a half a million French
citizens scattered throughout the French
empire.
So what was life like for these people?
Few men and women in the empire had lives
that were as exciting or as romantic
as the newspapers and popular songs
made the colonial experience out to be
despite being drawn to the empire by
the promise of adventure and prosperity.
Few people who went over
there found either disease,
took a large toll on French
people in the colonies,
many of whom fell victim
to malaria or yellow fever.
Dang gay fever.
Leprosy before they had spent
much time in the colony at all.
Attack was often always a concern.
In fact,
as we're accidents and deserts or jungles,
medical care in the colonies
was often pretty inadequate.
Working conditions were harsh.
Most settlers had,
for example,
had to build and maintain
their own houses,
clear forests or brush and
set up their own shops.
Colonial goods,
we're often susceptible
to rapidly changing market
conditions and many colonists
ended up in debt.
Many benefits offered by the French state
to its citizens didn't extend to the
empire and subsidies that people had
received to move to Algeria or to Morocco.
We're quickly exhausted.
Social life in the colonies
was pretty limited.
Bigger cities had theaters and some of
the art galleries and concert halls,
but in most places,
French citizens might spend months
without the side of another European.
Most of the French who lived in colonies
never abandoned the stereotypical
attitudes that they had
about their own superiority.
And these attitudes,
of course,
we're often reinforced by French laws
and institutions that gave whites more
privileges than indigenous populations.
For the most part,
life was really quite separate,
uh,
between,
between whites and other
European neighborhoods,
again,
had a town hall theater shops,
lining shaded streets and cafes.
Very often indigenous peoples
were separated from the
French by social barriers
and by physical barriers.
Sometimes markets and shops,
mosques and pagodas are often
apart from French colonial life.
So taking us now to world war one,
when the guns of August began to roar in,
in August,
1914,
the colonial empire was
very near its height.
Paris controlled the second
largest empire in the world,
second only to Britain's during the
40 years before the first world war.
The empire span these vast swathes of
north and west Africa and Southeast Asia,
enormous islands like Madagascar,
famous cities like Timbuktu,
and they'd even contain parts of India.
The crown jewel of the empire of
their fiercest national rival.
Colonial promoters lauded the benefits
of an empire that they said provided
international prestige,
secure place for investments,
a market for French products,
a source for raw materials,
and a reserve army of soldiers
and become a popular part of,
of,
of popular culture,
of daily life and even a career
for many French men and women.
In short,
empire had become a fundamental part of
the national identity and in some ways
the national hubris then
sweeping through France,
not only France,
but the rest of Europe as well.
Just as many in France cheered at the
declaration of war on Germany in 1914
we've no idea of what was to come.
Few French people in 1914 could see
any reason to think that anything might
threaten this eternal marriage between
France and it's outposts overseas between
the brave beneficence purveyors of French
civilization and the graceful natives
under French rule.
For many people.
France had recovered completely from its
devastating defeat in 1871 and from the
loss of assessed Lohan to once again
become a powerful nation empire.
Again.
Empire had been a central
part of this national revival.
As one member of the colonial
lobby said in 1912 quote,
it may be said that it
was colonial expansion,
which coming as it did just after the
events of 1871 brought the renewal of
France.
It was on the day that France
became a colonial power again.
That became once more conscious of her
vitality and her strength and was able to
resume her role in the concert of
Europe and on the world stage today,
1912 when that role is becoming so
important again in the concert of Europe,
when France finds herself in all parts
of the world on a footing with the
greatest European powers,
we may indeed be proud.
We may indeed be proud of the colonial
work which France has performed.
What was there to be proud of?
Again,
this idea of national expansion and
national greatness intimately tied to the
perceived positives benefits of
bringing French civilization abroad.
A member of the Chamber of Deputies
in fact answered this question,
what was there to be proud of?
What nobler or more inspiring work?
Good one find colonizing means coming in
touch with new races and civilizations
and it means achieving the noblest
type of fellowship for any form of
colonization which did not successfully
successfully seek to increase the
dignity,
the moral standards and the wellbeing
of the colonized people would be
uncivilized and unworthy of
a great nation and quote,
of course not all was well in the empire.
I focused in this lecture so far on the
place of the empire in domestic politics
and culture,
so I haven't spoken all that much about
the effect that French colonization had
on the lives of those in the colonies.
Needless to say,
the realities of empire did not often
coincide with as you'd failures,
promises to spread the
spread the best of friends,
civilization,
nor did it coincide with the
character of the smiling,
graceful African and the property at
popular press or on the front of the ban.
Yeah,
box on the breakfast table.
Empire.
Of course,
it was much more complicated than that.
A few people accepted the rise of
French power without a struggle,
but few could match the technological
advantage advantages then enjoyed by the
French military and the navy.
As the French empire spread,
soldiers and sailors put down one
resistance movement after another,
usually with uncompromising brutality
and often with very high death tolls.
As French colonial administrations,
legal systems,
police forces replaced the army
and the navy military repression.
What?
What had been military repression took
more of the character of an occupation
dressed up as integration,
the integration of the colonies
into the French nation.
French structures of authority enforced
to inequality between French and other
races and justified the exploitation of
resources and the political repression
that really where the realities of
everyday life for most of French colonial
subjects
cracks.
By 1914 however,
cracks began to appear in this edifice.
Not everybody had been swept
up by Francis colonial dreams,
and as the realities of empire
became more and more apparent,
a small anti-colonial lobby and France
began to grow like their counterparts in
the colonial lobby,
anti colonialists opposed French
expansion for a number of reasons.
For some people,
French colonial adventures seemed a
dangerous overextension of French power.
Some people wondered how useful these
dense jungles and barren deserts could
possibly be to France,
especially when it became clear that a
lot of the financial returns on colonial
expansion that had been expected
did not come to match these initial
projections.
Some people began to criticize
colonial expansion for moral reasons,
protesting the growing
incidences of colonial barbarity.
To give one example at one public protest
in 1906 the famous intellectual and
novelist and a total foss thundered
whites do not communicate with blacks or
yellow people except to
windsurf or massacre them.
The people whom we call barbarians.
No us only through our own crimes.
It is our responsibility as Frenchmen to
denounce the crimes being committed in
our name and quote [inaudible],
the leader of the Socialist Party went
even further refuting the myth of the
civilizing mission of the
[inaudible] in this case in Morocco.
Joe Has said,
quote,
there existed before the French takeover.
I'm Moroccan civilization capable
of the necessary transformation,
capable of evolution and progress.
A civil lays a civilization
both ancient and modern,
and there was a seed for the future.
There was a hope,
and let me say that I cannot pardon those
who have crushed this hope for Pacific
and human progress.
African civilization by all sorts of
roses and by the brutality of conquest and
quote during the 1920s in 1930s anti
colonialism would become a more powerful
force in French politics.
Grouping together some
socialists and communists,
some voices within the
French Catholic Church,
journalists and writers and a number of
intellectuals and avant garde artists,
a ladder of whom would famously organized
an anti-colonial counter exposition
during the famous 1931
colonial exposition in Venice.
Then in 1900 and Paris there had been
no similar anti-colonial exposition.
However,
and I want to underscore this,
it was not the French themselves who
would eventually succeed in crumbling the
imperial edifice built over
so many generations when
the French colonial empire
eventually expired in 1962
when the French left Algeria,
it did so first and foremost because of
the many forms of resistance organized
and carried out by those
who lived under it's yolk.
That's another topic for another lecture,
but what I want to say here is sort of
in conclusion is that the first world war
was in many ways the beginning of the
end for the French colonial empire.
It was a tipping point after which
these myths underpinning French rural,
we're no longer sustainable.
These are,
they'd been very powerful
myths before World War One,
many in the colonized world had
actually asked themselves whether French
civilization might in fact
be superior to their own.
The French had arrived with technological
advantages that many in the colonized
world did not have,
and that achieved military and
political control with few numbers.
For some people,
it did seem for a time that what the
French were saying about the missile and
CBDS,
that case the civilizing mission
might actually in fact be true.
But for many of these people,
World War One was a
revelation during the war,
nearly half a million colonial subjects
were conscripted or even volunteered,
and many of them did to don the BW blue
uniform of the [inaudible] and to fight
for France,
many others came to the Metropol to
work in shipyards are in factories.
Those who came,
saw poverty.
They saw deep rifts in French
society over the place of religion,
uh,
over politics.
And most importantly,
they saw their omnipotent colonial masters
in a war that was literally ripping
French civilization apart.
Although those who came to
France to fight or to work,
we're very small minority
of colonial subjects.
The echoes of the guns of
August reverberated worldwide
and for countless people
throughout the empire.
The Great War showed that France,
for all its power,
did not and could not correspond
to its own colonial myths.
This in the minds of other races would
write the governor general of Indochina
in 1931 in the minds of other races,
the war delta terrible blow to the
moral standing of a civilization which
Europeans claimed with
pride to be superior,
yet in whose name European spent more
than four years savagely killing each
other.
Europe's prestige had
been greatly compromised.
It has long been commonplace to contrast
European greatness with Asian or
African decadence.
The contrast now seems to be reversed.
Indeed,
empire would have a very different
relationship to national identity in the
years after world war one for
growing numbers of people in France,
empire slowly came to seem
too difficult to maintain.
Too expensive,
especially during the lean years of the
Depression in the 1930s and perhaps for
many even immoral,
what had been a point of unification in
France slowly turned into a source for
political and cultural tension,
but the opposite was true or
the Francis of the places,
places that France had colonized.
Indeed during the 1920s and 1930s
national identities will be formed outside
France,
throughout the French empire in
opposition to the French colonial project.
As anti-colonial activists laid the
roots for liberation movements that would
ultimately tear down the French colonial
empire in the years after the Second
World War.
And that's a subject for another lecture.
Thanks very much.